bonjour à toutes et à tous c'est paléo
news l'émission qui traînait news avec
du vieux alors on va commencer une
petite session de rattrapage de ce que
vous avez peut-être ou pas rater pendant
les vacances et de ce que moi j'ai raté
pendant l'année dernière parce qu'il ya
quelques articles dont je n'ai pas parlé
l'année dernière et dont j'aurais dû
parler parce que quand même c'était des
news assez sympa donc on va diviser
cette petite vidéo en deux parties les
rattrapages des vacances et les
rattrapages de tout 2021 donc on
commence par les news qui sont sortis
pendant les vacances et évidemment vous
n'avez certainement pas rater ce enfin
cette image le vix raptor dans son oeuf
magnifique
vous l'avez certainement vu passer sur
twitter j'ai partagé cette photo-là sur
twitter donc cette image qui a fait le
tour d'internet en général pas seulement
par mes réseaux sociaux évidemment mais
aussi bien tous les médias l'ont
repartager c'est donc l'oeuf dans nos
vies raptor qui nous vient évidemment de
du désert de gobi donc il me semble que
c'est la partie chinoise non c'est pas
du désert de gobi mais c'est des niveaux
équivalents au désert de gobi donc fin
du crétacé et chinois côté chinois et
vous avez ici la reconstruction donc de
7 ils l'ont fait jaune poussin histoire
que ça ressemble bien un petit poulet
mais voilà on voit tout quoi il ya le
crâne ici la colonne vertébrale là le
bassin le pied enfin la jambe ici qui
est replié on voit là les os du bras
normalement qui sont ici voilà les os du
bras qui sont dans ce coin là et puis
évidemment on a la queue juste là donc
ça c'est l'image qui a circulé et qui a
eu beaucoup de succès et cette image
elle nous vient de cet article article
qui nous est proposée par line linda
xing et ses collègues notamment stephen
brusatte qui est désormais relativement
célèbre même même dans le web
francophone j'ai envie de dire puisque
c'est lui qui est le conseiller sur
jurassique world dominion
jack horner
a été a été retiré du jeu et maintenant
c'est stephen brusatte qui le remplace
et vous avez certainement vu passer son
livre récemment sur les dinosaures un
livre qui est sorti enfin qui a été
traduit tout récemment en français sur
les dinosaures donc bref et ligne daxing
que vous connaissez certainement pour
aucune lui dans ta vie ce voile à linda
xing qui est donc était qui était aussi
premier auteur l'ida pardon l'ida xing
qui était premier auteur / au cul lui
dans ta vie ce qui est le petit oiseau
retrouver enfin le crâne d'oiseaux
retrouvés dans l'ombre qui était en fait
pas un oiseau mais un lézard et lambres
venus de birmanie donc c'était aussi
quelque chose de très
éthiquement contester puisque en
birmanie basiquement c'est des esclaves
entre guillemets des ouvriers en tout
cas sous payés et surchargé qui qui
extraient lambres dans lequel les
fossiles se trouve bon là il n'y a pas
de problème éthique avec en tout cas pas
qu'on sache pour l'instant il n'y a pas
de problème éthique avec cet ovni raptor
puisqu'il vient de chine voilà donc
c'est des chercheurs chinois dit eising
et ses collègues chercheurs chinois qui
travaillent sur des fossiles chinois
donc a priori vers s'il ya un problème
éthique cde eux mêmes avec eux-mêmes
donc pour l'instant il n'y a pas de
problème à ce niveau là il ya une
transparence assez assez nette sur
l'origine du fossile pas de souci alors
donc ce fossile il vient de 7,2 cette
publication là et alors ce qui m'a quand
j'ai lu la publication en fait ce qui
m'a vraiment intéressé j'ai envie de
dire c'est à quel point il ya eu un
engouement sur internet à propos de ce
fossile qui est très jolie un jeu diriez
très très très joli mais là on sait le
contraste en fait entre l'engouement
qu'a suscité le fossile est ce que ce
fossile nous apprend réellement de
nouveau parce que dans l'absolu c'est à
novi raptor enfin me vire ap torride et
on n'est pas capable de l'identifier
mieux que ça mais c'est un avis rap
torride et mais des hommes brion d'envy
rap torride et dans leur zone on en
avait déjà trouvé avant
il est joliment rouler certes mais des
embryons joliment enroulait on en avait
déjà trouvé un vent et des plus vieux
que ça ça date du crétacé mais du début
du jurassique on amuse sorrus et ma
sauce pon di luce donc voilà par exemple
ma sauce pandy luce un embryon de ma
sauce pon di luce dans son oeuf on voit
la membrane enfin le petit bout de
coquilles a par exemple et puis là aussi
donc c'est un masos pondi luz dans son
oeuf et il est bien enroulé tout pareil
avec les os de la jambe ici les os du
bras là
donc c'est pas nouveau non plus d'avoir
un embryon dans son f c'est pas non plus
le plus vieux embryons dans son oeuf
cd fossile donc comme je les dis qu'ils
viennent du désert de gobi et des
niveaux équivalents en chine
donc c'est pas rare de trouver des
choses très très bien préservés à cet
endroit là au delà du fait qu'il est
très joli et ça je suis d'accord c'est
un superbe fossiles je suis jaloux mais
au delà du fait que ce fossile est très
jolie êtes vous capable de me dire ce
qu'on a appris grâce à ce pot s'il
bat allez-y c'est pas évident c'est pas
évident donc ce que nous a appris ce
fossile
c'est c'est que comme les oiseaux les
aux virades torride et bougeait dans
l'oeuf en fait vers la fin de leur
développement ce qu'on appelle le taking
ils se déplacent dans l'oeuf est en fait
la tête passe en dessous du bras ce qui
a priori leur donne un meilleur angle
d'attaqué pour péter la coquille c'est
la seule chose nouvelle que ce fossile
nous apprend donc c'est c'est pas
inattendu je veux dire les eaux-de-vie
raptor les aubiers raptor idée étant
parmi ces dinosaures théropodes très
très proche des oiseaux
en plus ils ont un bec donc je veux dire
on s'attendait pas autre chose j'ai
envie de dire il ya une chose qui a
contribué au succès enfin au fait que ce
truc a fait le buzz c'est qu'il ya des
gens qui ont compris je sais pas trop
comment mais qui ont compris qu'on avait
un embryon de dinosaures vivants en fait
ce qui évidemment il ya des les médias
les médias qui n'ont pas envie de
partager des photos de fossiles au lieu
de partager cette photo là on partageait
cette photo là bon moi j'avais moi
j'avais fait exprès à montage pour
mettre le fossile avec le animal en même
temps histoire que justement on
comprenne que la reconstruction venait
pas de nulle part mais comme la plupart
des médias ont partagé directement le
fossile enfin la reconstruction elle
même est pas la photo du fossile il ya
des gens qui ont cru vous voyez le rêve
enfin c'est quand même une
reconstruction hyper réaliste et vous
verrez il ya des vidéos aller voir les
vidéos de ce truc là et il ya des vidéos
qui sont très très belle 2 parce que ça
c'est une sculpture 3d et qui a été
aussi animée du coup donc il ya des
vidéos de ce truc là animé c'est assez
impressionnant
bref il ya des médias qui ont partagé
uniquement ça et du coup c'est tellement
réaliste qu'il ya des gens qui ont cru
on avait vraiment recréer un dinosaure
mais non
évidemment que non tout ça part du
fossile fossiles ça ça me rappelle quand
j'étais gamin et que quand on parlait
d'embryons de dinosaures moi je me
représentais pas un embryon fossilisés
de dinosaures je me représentais un
embryon de dinosaures vivants quoi mais
non c'est pas parce qu'on retrouve un
embryon de dinosaure dans son oeuf que
le dinosaure et vivant à l'intérieur
c'est un embryon fossilisé donc je pense
que ça a dû participer au buzz qu'a
généré 7 cette nouvelle on reste dans
les reptiles géants du mésozoïque avec
maintenant des mots des ichtyosaures
parlons pas des mozart justement des
ichtyosaures dont on était au crétacé
mais maintenant on part dans les confins
du trias aux alentours de 246 millions
d'années pour découvrir donc simple
bosse pondi us s'impose pont d'eus dont
je veux vous montrer le crâne voyez
c'est un très joli crâne très très bien
préservés et qui fait à peu près deux
mètres de long dont qui est à peu près
qui est plus grand que moi
je fais un mètre quatre-vingt donc c'est
un crâne qui est quand même plus grand
qu'à un grand chantier aussi grand qu'un
très grand êtres humains voilà donc
c'est juste le crâne donc c'est quand
même assez balèze c'est un très très
beau spécimen de symboles condé lui sait
alors ce qu'il ya d'intéressant à propos
de ce spécimen c'est que c'est un très
très grand ici aux orres qui vient du
trias et pas de n'importe quand dans le
trias il à
246 millions d'années
246 millions d'années alors l'extinction
permien trias c'est à dire le début du
trias ses 252 millions d'années
les ichthyosaures apparaissent à 249
millions d'années donc quasi
instantanément je veux dire seulement
trois millions d'années après
l'extinction permien trias et à 246
millions d'années on a déjà des monstres
comme saint baudile us st bo ce pont dit
luce qui a reconstitué ici on a déjà des
monstres de avec des crânes de deux
mètres de long et du coup ça fait dire à
ces a fait comparé à ses auteurs ça leur
a fait comparer en fait l'évolution du
gigantisme chez les équipiers aux orres
comparé aux cétacés c'est ce qui est
représenté sur ce graphe donc vous avez
les ichthyosaures en bleu foncé vous
avez les cétacés ici en bleu clair et
vous avez le temps ici et vous avez la
taille donc la taille du corps ici c'est
en échelle logarithmique je pense parce
que 0,2 0,4 ça mais ça m'étonnerait que
non c'est pas une échelle logarithmique
ça doit être en tonnes du coup mais en
tout cas c'est la taille et la chose
qu'il faut voir en groupe c'est que vous
voyez les cétacés donc c'est l'origine
des cétacés et l'origine des
ichtyosaures est placé sur le zéro parce
qu'évidemment si on les mettait sur une
échelle de temps géologique
l'origine des cétacés elle serait par là
sur la droite de l'écran mais elle a
donc l'origine des cétacés et l'origine
des ecchymoses ans est placé sur le zéro
et en fait vous voyez que les taille
géante chez les cétacés ne sont atteints
que sur la toute fin de leur évolution
alors que les taille géante chez les
ichthyosaures sont atteintes
immédiatement au début de leur évolution
et ça c'est intéressant fait les
ichthyosaures ont d'abord commencé par
être gigantesque alors en réalité ils
ont d'abord commencé par se diversifier
en termes de taille
vous voyez qu'il ya une explosion dès le
départ d'une grande variété de tailles
des plus petits aux plus grands et
qu'ensuite cette variété de tailles va
diminuer diminué diminuer jusqu'à
atteindre des tailles modéré modéré
grande sur la fin de l'évolution des
dinosaures des ichtyosaures roi je vais
y arriver donc c'est en fait les
ichthyosaures ont fait le chemin inverse
des cétacés les cétacés ont démarré avec
très peu de diversité taille et ont
ensuite augmenter la diversité de leur
taille avec aujourd'hui on a tout du
marsouin qui est un petit
enfin jusqu'à la baleine bleue qui est
le plus grand animal qui ait jamais vécu
et chez les ichthyosaures celle inverse
en fait ils ont tous fait au trias et
puis arrivé à l'arrivée au crétacé juste
avant qu'ils s'éteignent ben alors une
gt gt peu peur dans leur zone de confort
en fait ils ont réduit leur zone de
confort si vous voulez au fur et à
mesure qu'elle évolue et
donc c'est plutôt intéressant et je
enfin cet article du cou qui est paru
qui a fait un gros papier c'est paru
dans science donc c'est quand même un
gros truc
cet article donc ce essaye d'expliquer
pourquoi mais le fait est qu'on n'y
arrive pas vraiment enfin évidemment ils
mettent ça sur l'abondance de nourriture
puisque ce nouveau symbole qu'on dit
luce a été découvert dans une formation
qui est très très riches en autres
fossiles notamment de dabo no id donc il
ya beaucoup beaucoup de nourriture ce
qu'ils disent en tout cas c'est que ya
beaucoup de nourriture qui était
accessible à ce symbole ce ponte di luce
donc oui l'existence de grand ici aux
orres était possible maintenant là la
question du pourquoi
sont ils devenus géant et puis ya aussi
la question du comment sont ils devenus
géant parce qu on est juste après
l'extinction permien trias bon il faut
il faut bien l'admettre que juste après
l'extinction permien trias on est dans
un environnement qui est extrêmement
perturbé donc en fait déjà on est sur un
environnement qui a beaucoup de niches
écologiques vacante et on est sur un
environnement qui est aussi extrêmement
perturbé donc qui entre guillemets
permet un peu toutes les excentricités
voilà alors que les cétacés ils trouvent
leur origine quand même assez longtemps
après en tout cas les premiers fossiles
de cétacés viennent assez longtemps un
trait l'extinction crétacé tertiaire
au moins donc au moins 50 50 millions
d'années au moins 10 millions d'années
après les premiers fossiles de cétacés
en 53 milliards d'années donc les
extinctions crétacé-tertiaire à 66
millions d'années donc on est à 13
millions d'années de différence
et donc il commence petit et ils ne vont
pas se diversifier immédiatement donc
c'est intéressant en fait deux
contrastes et les deux et c'est donc un
phénomène intéressant bien que
honnêtement même cet article qui tente
de répondre à la question du pourquoi
est un peu léger au niveau des réponses
mais bon c'est pas une question facile
non plus donc on s'attendait pas non
plus à ce qu'ils trouvent une réponse
magique comme ça voilà mais n'empêche
que les ichthyosaures après trois
millions d'années en fait avait déjà
atteint le maximum de diversité en
termes de taille corporelle 3 millions
d'années après leur apparition les avais
déjà
il avait conquis plus de niches
écologiques en termes de taille
corporelle qui ne vont jamais en occuper
après le trias parce qu'en plus ce qu'il
faut voir c'est que une fois passée une
fois passé le trias voilà par là bas il
y aura plus d'ici aux ordres aussi grand
appart est une ode au taurus c'est ce
qu'ils disent un peu plus loin les
ichthyosaures les plus grands se sont
chauds ni aux russes avec un crâne de
deux mètres de mettre 75 et charges tazo
russe avec un crâne de 3 m et tout ça
c'est du trias c'est ce qu'ils disent
ici voilà de la fin du trias et vous
avez techno d'auto aux russes qui est un
des plus grands aussi et qui lui est
bien du jurassique inférieur donc on est
juste après c'est littéralement ce qui
vient juste après le trias supérieur
donc au trias donc pendant le trias et
au début du jurassique les eti aux
offres sont gigantesques et d'un seul
coup il arrête d'être gigantesque il
trouve une zone de confort ailleurs et
ne retourneront plus à des tailles
gigantesques non c'est plutôt
intéressant comme patterns c'est un
article aussi qui est intéressant parce
qu'il nous rappelle pourquoi les et
pourquoi on préfère travailler sur des
tailles de crâne plutôt que sur des
taille corporelle
parce que là vous voyez l'état corporel
estimé pour symbole qu'on dit luce
vont de 44 tonnes à
135 tonnes
c'est quand même pas mal non même pas
assez la moyenne est à 44 tonnes
le maximum et à 135 tonnes et le minimum
estimé est à 14 tonnes
donc vous avez quand même entre 14 et
tonnes et 135 tonnes ya quand même un
facteur 10 entre les deux il ya un ordre
de grandeur entre les deux donc je vous
rappelle notre petite vidéo sur le
brachiosaure et quel était le plus gros
dinosaures c'est exactement ce qu'on
vous dit à la fin c'est les estimations
de taille corporelle
faut pas s'y fier on peut pas s'y fier
dans l'absolu faut les détails de
corporelle relatif qu'il faut comparer
mais on peut pas s'y fier dans l'absolu
c'est pour ça qu'il regarde c'est pour
ça que tous leurs graffs et toutes leurs
études sont faites sur la taille du
crâne et rien d'autre même si la
proportion du crâne par rapport au reste
du corps change chez les ichthyosaures
les premiers ichthyosaures ayant un
crâne relativement court par rapport au
reste du corps comparé aux ichthyosaures
tardif j'ai envie de dire qui eux
avaient un crâne relativement gros par
rapport au reste du corps le problème
c'est qu'on peut pas se fier à ses
estimations de masques il faut
absolument regarder en face ses
estimations de poids il faut regarder
une métrique qui est comparable entre
tous les individus quad et ça c'est la
taille du crâne c'est encore c'est
encore ce qu'on fait de mieux voilà donc
c'est une étude qui est très très
intéressante parce qu'elle pose des
questions très très intéressante et
notamment cette question du mais qu'est
ce qui s'est passé avec les fa c'est
quoi la différence finalement train
c'est assez un ichtyosaure pour que les
deux aient suivi des trajectoires
évolutif si différentes alors qu'au
final les ichthyosaures c'est quand même
les trucs qui vont ressembler plus à des
dauphins les ichthyosaures du crétacé
rire quand il ressemble quand même un
mort à des dauphins la convergence
évolutive et extrêmement frappante
mais pourtant ces issues de trajectoire
évolutive extrêmement différentes une
des explications qu'ils avancent dans
l'article c'est que les mysticètes donc
ils sont les plus gros cétacés sont
devenus gros après justement que ba qu'
il ya eu un refroidissement du climat
qui a amené des zones de un poil ling
qui a donc ramené du krill finalement
pas qu'ils ramènent des nutriments qui
nous nourrit le krill et donc les
cétacés ont commencé à évoluer des
tailles gigantesques
par adaptation à cette nouvelle
abondance de nourriture on va dire un
truc qu'il ne rappelle pas et qui à mon
avis valait le coup d'être rappelée sait
aussi que
c'est l'énorme l'énorme contribution des
requins dans cette histoire enfin les
chondrites tient l'est pas seulement les
requins les chondrites tient en général
puisque à l'époque des ichtyosaures vous
avez les ibode ontils forme qui sont les
congrès tient dominant et à l'époque des
cétacés vous avez les requins qui sont
des cons briques tient de 2000 a en tout
cas les congrès tient pélagiques
dominant elles et les poissons
cartilagineux décombres il tient les le
fait est qu au trias il n'y a pas tant
de condrieu tient que ça en tout cas on
trouve certainement pas autant de
condrieu tient au trias qu'on en trouve
au début du cénozoïque est donc ce
retard on va dire d'évolution et
j'aurais bien aimé voir une discussion
dans cet article mais il n'en parle pas
mais à mon avis ce retard d'évolution
des mysticètes fin des cétacés en
général en termes de taille corporelle
ce retard doit avoir quelque chose à
voir à mon avis avec les requins avec
l'abondance de requins en général à la
fin du crétacé et au début du paléogène
et après il ya peut-être une influence
aussi parce que évidemment le ce qu'ils
ont fait là c'est ces mesures et le
temps d'évolution depuis le premier
fossile
cette échelle là que vous voyez là 2-0 à
150 millions d'années c'est depuis le
premier fossile jusqu'au dernier
fossiles enfin jusqu'au plus récent j'ai
envie de dire
or
peut-être qu'il nous manque une partie
de l'évolution des ichtyosaures les it
is or ils apparaissent à 249 millions
d'années donc trois millions d'années
après la limite permise trias
il est pas complètement impossible et ce
sont déjà des animaux aquatiques voilà
quand ils apparaissent ils ont déjà les
mains transformés en palettes natatoire
donc contrairement aux cétacés en fait
on n'a pas encore dit ti aux orres non
aquatique alors que pour les cétacés on
en a pas qui s'est tenue ce qui est
quand même enfin qui est amphibie mais
il est pas complètement aquatique alors
que pour les exposants on n'a pas encore
de représentants amphibie voir terrestre
pour les cétacés en a pas qui c'est us
et on a un don il y eut ce qui lui pour
le coup a vraiment la morphologie d'un
animal complètement terrestre donc donc
peut-être qu'on a aussi un problème de
préservation du registre fossile qui
fait qu' il nous manque une grosse
partie une petite ou une grosse partie
du registre fossile des ichthyosaures
qui fait qu'on a l'impression que d'un
seul coup ils apparaissent et sont très
diversifiés alors qu'en réalité on a
juste un énorme une énorme ligne et
fantômes ceci étant dit pour que pour
que les
ichthyosaures
enfin pour que l'évolution en termes de
taille corporelle des ichtyosaures puis
se caler avec celle des cétacés il
faudrait 50 millions d'années or poussé
d'origine des ichtyosaures 50 millions
d'années à 50 millions d'années plus tôt
que 249 millions d'années ça nous amène
quand même au début du permien donc un
ichtyosaure du permis à inférieur ce
serait quand même malaise le permis est
inférieur je vous rappel c'est l'époque
c'est l'époque de 10 mais trop dans quoi
il faudrait admettre qu'on ait une ligne
et fantômes d'à peu près 50 millions
d'années et que cette lignée fantôme
nous ramène à l'époque de 10 métro dont
à une époque où il est enfin je veux
dire c'est la pangée à 250 il ya 300
millions d'années la pangée est encore
assez solidement assemblée il n'y a pas
beaucoup de maires de
d'endroits de côtes j'ai envie de dire
qu'ils seraient propices au
développement de espèces
d'espèces semi aquatique
à l'époque l'espèce semi-aquatique la
plus connue à l'époque ces maisons aux
rythmes et aux russes n'a rien à voir
avec un 10 kg d'or en tout cas pour
autant qu'on sache mais c'est le plus
célèbre des des âmes mignotte amphibies
du début du début du permien bon bref
c'est en tout cas c'est un article qui
pose d'intéressantes questions même si
il même si les réponses vont devoir
attendre la fin j'ai envie de dire
les réponses vont devoir attendre c'est
en tout cas un article qu'ils méritent
d'être publiés dans un gros journal
comme ça le matériel est excellent les
études sont son béton et ce qu'il nous
apprend est vraiment très très très
intéressant donc ça c'est que de la
bonne on reste dans le gigantisme avec
maintenant arthro pleura une fois n'est
pas coutume je vais parler d'invertébrés
dont car trop peu le race etc etc pour
ceux qui ne le connaissent pas le gros
mille pattes du alors il est connu pour
être du carbonifère mais en réalité les
arts trop peu leurs idées ce sont les
myriapodes du moins on les interprète
comme des myriapodes ce sont des
myriapodes qui ont vécu au carbonifère
et aussi au début du permien et donc
c'est césar trop pleura ce sont des
arthropodes qui sont connus pour avoir
des pour être terrestre d'une part dont
se sont pas des sont pas des crustacés
quoi ce sont vraiment des animaux qui
vivent sur terre strictement sur terre
donc d'une part ce sont des arthropodes
qui sont connus pour être terrestre mais
aussi pour avoir atteint des tailles
gigantesques donc comme comme des tas
d'autres arthropodes comme la mégane
europe si ce qui nous met gagnera qui
sont ces libellule géante voilà les
palets oddity optèrent aussi enfin vous
avez plein d'autres arthropodes qui
avait le carbonifère c'est connu comme
étant l'époque des arthropodes géant de
manière générale des arthropodes
terrestre géant arthro pleura est l'un
des plus célèbres de ces arthropodes
géant avec la mégane aura par exemple
vous avez megara cne qui est devenu très
connu à la cause du reportage de la bbc
mais mes gars arachne en fait c'est pas
du tout une araignée ils ont replacé sa
parmi les horribles terrible je crois si
je me rappelle bien donc les scorpions
de mer finalement vers deux donc c'est
du coup c'est plus la verte est vrai
enfin c'est plus un arthropode terrestre
du coup mes gars hackney maintenance est
redevenu un or it and ripped héritent
donc un averti bray aquatique bref
arthro pleura et donc c'est on a un
nouveau fossile d' art rock le rat qui
nous vient d'angleterre et qui est un
petit bout alors d'une exigence est à
dire enfin petit bout petit bout par
rapport à l'animal mais vous voyez là
l'échelle elle fait
5 cm donc on a un truc qui fait la
moitié d'un mètre de long quand même et
c'est juste un fragment probablement
proche de la tête ce que vous voyez ici
là là c'est un bout de la tête
apparemment qui est préservée qu'il
redessiner la qui se trouve à ici donc
sur le spécimen
c'est un fragment de dunes et xvi c'est
à dire d'une mue d'un art rope leur idée
puisque comme tout les arthropodes il
muet est donc cet article est très
intéressant parce qu'il nous dit que
c'est le plus gros fragment d'un art
troublera qu'on n'ait jamais retrouver
un individu dont la taille va dont le
poids mais alors bon je vous rappelle
toutes les petites et petites conditions
qu'il faut mettre aux estimations de
poids évidemment mais c'est un individu
dont le poids est estimé entre 55 et 85
kg avec une longueur possible allant
jusqu'à 2 m 62 long de mettre 60 de long
c'est quasiment c'est un être humain il
me quoi de long c'est ce qu'on voit ici
un gros gros myriapodes donc est
probablement le plus gros jamais
découvert en tout cas par des parts des
fossiles du corps enfin des fossiles de
l'animal lui même donc on avait des
grosses empreintes de voyez ici vous
avez les repeints les empreintes
représenté à l'échelle avec le fossile
qu'ils viennent de découvrir donc avec
une longueur estimée de 2 mètres 60 et
ici vous avez les emprunte donc on avait
des empreintes qui allaient qui selon
les estimations auraient pu appartenir à
des individus de plus de 2 m
mais cet individu la haine de son de sa
taille estimée plus grand et est le
premier à être représentés par des
fossiles un fossile du corps en réalité
donc au lieu des empreintes uniquement
en france on en a aussi des deux césar
troupes le ride enfin deux mêmes des
arts troupes le rat on a une belle carte
qui nous montre la distribution de tous
les arts trop peur à qui ont été
découverts
et en france ici vous voyez on a un
monceau les mines notamment un martre
hop le rap quasiment complet mais qui
est en fait qui est petit en faut-il
conserver dans un module dans une
ancienne
de charbon qui a été découvert donc ils
ont cassé le nodule et à l'intérieur du
dodu il y avait un trop pleura complet
mais c'est un petit spécimens c'est pas
un spécimen gigantesque comme celui-là
mais en même temps plus ils sont grands
et plus c'est difficile d'avoir du
matériel complet donc on a quand même
pas mal de pas mal d'art trop tard trop
pleura en france et en belgique vous
voyez donc partout en fait vous voyez ça
suis complètement la distribution des
bassins miniers du carbonifère ceci dit
à trop pleura n'a pas seulement vécu au
carbonifère mais a aussi vécu au permien
donc voilée s'est il a quand même vécu
jusqu'au début du permien et ça ça a
conduit à une discussion intéressante je
trouve c'est qu'il ya cette idée qui est
persistante et qui est souvent discutée
mais bon bah on a c'est une idée qu'on
garde à défaut de mieux j'ai envie de
dire et qui est que c'est l'abondance
d'oxygène qui a permis aux arthropodes
de devenir gigantesque pendant le
carbonifère et le permien c'est vrai que
le carbonifère et le début du permien
c'est là où il ya eu le plus d'oxygène
sur terre avec des pics jusqu'à 30%
d'oxygène au lieu de 20% comme
aujourd'hui donc 21% il me semble
aujourd'hui donc vous avez des pics de
concentration en oxygène dans
l'atmosphère au carbonifère et au début
du permien qui aurait permis donc aux
arthropodes de mieux absorber l'oxygène
je rappelle qu'ils ont pas de poumons
ils ont des trous sur les côtés et que
ces trous sur les côtés amène l'oxygène
directement aux organes voilà c'est bon
c'est efficace mais pas tant que ça en
réalité parce que justement si vous avez
une concentration trop faible en oxygène
c'est un système qui devient très
inefficace et du coup vous êtes obligés
de réduire la taille du corps pour
augmenter proportionnellement la surface
je vous rappelle que le volume du corps
grandi au cube et la surface seulement
au carré donc plus vous avez de volume -
vous avez proportionnellement de surface
est comme en l'occurrence avec ce
système qui envoie directement l'oxygène
dans les organes basse et la surface qui
va être critique bien plus que le volume
donc là la surface est le facteur
limitant ce qui fait que si vous avez
une concentration moindre en oxygène bas
vous pouvez vous ne pouvez pas atteindre
de grosses talent donc la théorie qui
est généralement la plus communément
admise les arthropodes ont atteint de
grande taille pendant le carbonifère
albert bien parce que il y avait
beaucoup d'oxygène dans l'atmosphère il
y avait une concentration une très haute
concentration d'oxygène dans
l'atmosphère
est en fait là cet article apporte un
contre argument assez intéressant je
trouve
qui est en fait car trop pleura n'a pas
un registre fossile qui est
le registre fossile d'art trop pleuré en
fait elle ne se corel pas avec les pics
de concentration en oxygène qu'on
observe durant le carbonifère début du
permien et à mon avis l'argument le plus
intéressant c'est que le spécimen donc
qui est décrit dans cet article la lui
provient d'une strate géologique qui
s'est formée à une période durant
laquelle la concentration en oxygène et
cet été seulement 2 23% contre les 30%
qui ont eu lieu pendant ces fameux peak
dont on vient de parler ce qui n'est pas
très différent de ce qu'on voit
aujourd'hui les 21% d'aujourd'hui donc
le plus grand art trouvera qu'on ait
retrouvé jusqu'à présent ne l'a pas vécu
à une époque où le tourner d'oxygène
était très différent de celui
d'aujourd'hui et aujourd'hui on n'a pas
d'insectes géants fin n'a pas
d'arthropodes géant voici un arthro
pleura géant qui vivait à une époque où
l'oxygène était pas où la concentration
en oxygène était pas si haute que ça et
ce n'est pas et c'est une mue ce qui
veut dire que l'animal était vivant
quand il a formé ce fossile et continuer
de grandir donc ça veut dire que
globalement
cette mue appartient à un animal en
bonne santé voilà il n'avait pas l'air
de galérer il cadrait pas sa race pour
survivre donc c'est intéressant moi je
trouve et et même si à mon avis
l'hypothèse de l'oxygène de la haute
concentration en oxygène a encore un bel
avenir devant elle parce qu'elle
explique un peu trop bien ce qui s'est
passé avec les arthropodes à cette
époque c'est intéressant de voir que
justement il y à des éléments contre qui
sont découverts même encore aujourd'hui
on reste chez les invertébrés avec
maintenant les céphalopodes nos
mollusques céphalopodes les poulpes donc
les poulpes dont le le plus ancien
fossile enfin les poules les
céphalopodes pas les poules le plus
ancien fossile de poule vient de
vient d'ardèche
du fameux gisement de la voulte sur
rhône et date du jurassique si je ne
m'abuse mais le plus ancien fossile de
céphalopode jusqu'à cet article datait
de la fin du cambrien et maintenant ils
nous proposent un nouveau fossile vous
voyez ici qui ressemble beaucoup à un
ordre toscer vous voyez ici donc les
cloisons ici les chambres qui ont des
cloisons relativement simples comme un
art auxerre et vous voyez ici le siphon
alors en position ni totalement centrale
ni totalement excentré
donc c'est un rappel à la fois les
orthos air et les hameaux no id mais en
tout cas on a un très beau fossiles ici
vous voyez avec lala par exemple
typiquement le siphon a quand même l'air
plus en position plus en position
excentrée comme les hameaux de rides
mais bon en tout cas il ya un siphon il
ya des ja des cloisons donc il ya des
chambres à l'intérieur de ce cône
donc ça ressemble quand même vachement
1-1 morteau sert à l'idée qu'on se fait
en général d'un céphalopode du début du
cambrien donc ce céphalopode il nous est
dit qu il à 522 millions d'années qu'il
nous vient donc de terre-neuve
newfoundland au canada c'est terre-neuve
et si on accepte ce fossile comme étant
un céphalopode eh bien ils repousserait
l'origine des céphalopodes de 30
millions d'années en arrière c'est un
changement assez radical là qui vient de
se produire et donc ça aligne aussi un
peu mieux le registre fossile avec ce
qu'on sait de la palio de la génétique
parce qu'avec la génétique on utilise
l'horloge moléculaire qui permet de
dater l'origine de certains groupes en
l'absence d'un registre fossile et en
l'occurrence les céphalopodes il y avait
un il y avait une grosse ligne et
fantômes il ya toujours une brousse
ligne et fantômes d'ailleurs entre
l'origine mesurée par horloge
moléculaire
et le premier fossile mais maintenant en
tout cas cette lignée fantôme est
raccourci si on admet encore une fois
l'identification de ce fossile comme
étant à céphalopode bas
cette lignée fantôme est désormais la
course de 30 millions d'années bon c'est
quand même pas rien sans transition on
retourne aux êtres humains pour une fois
on va terminer avec les êtres humains
alors on va pas exactement terminé avec
les êtres humains puisque on a encore
tous les rattrapages a fermé en tout cas
voilà première article de 2022 voilà
tout ce que je vous ai présenté jusqu'à
présent c'était ce qui était sorti
pendant les vacances en 2021 premier
article de 2022 et ce premier article de
2002 concernent homo ludens hisse donc
si vous ne savez pas qui est homo ludens
ys je vous mets un petit lien dans la
description faite moi penser à lemaitre
comme d'habitude si j'ai oublié petit
lien dans la description vers la vidéo
que nous avons faites ont fait une vidéo
entièrement consacré à cet homo ludens
hills pour expliquer ce que c'était d'où
il sortait etc pour vous la faire courte
au mollet zone n 6 c'est un nouveau
représentant du genre homo qui vient
d'asie qui vient des philippines et qui
a été découvert il ya seulement deux
trois ans voilà et donc il y avait une
grande question sûr il ya toujours une
grande question sur mais d'où vient
qu'on bouge lui zone n 6 il est
suffisamment différent des autres
espèces du genre homo pour qu'on lui
attribue sa propre espèce mais doté de
t'exciter qui sort cet homo l'usiné de 6
c'est quoi son histoire à lui est bien
ce que nous apprend cet article alors en
étudiant les temps avec des techniques
morpho métriques assez pointue que je
n'ai pas besoin de détailler pour en
expliquer les résultats mais en gros ce
que nous dit cet article est bien c'est
que homo l'usm n 6 en fait on va déjà il
faut voir la taille des dents domo luz
n6 donc cch numéro qui commence par cchc
au mollet jeunes 6 donc vous voyez vous
prenez les prémolaires voulez comparer à
homo erectus à néanderthal et ben vous
voyez que elles sont plus petites elles
sont relativement similaires en termes
de taille à celle de l'homme de florès
qui est représentée ici par lb un pareil
pour les molaires vous avez cch donc au
mollet zone n 6 là vous avez homo
erectus vous avez molaires de néandertal
est ici vous avez une molaire 2 homo
floresiensis l'homme de florès vous
voyez que les tailles sont assez
similaires donc et déjà il est très
fortement possible que homo lui zone n 6
est comme homo floresiensis subi ce
qu'on appelle un nanisme insulaire c'est
à dire que les philippines c'est une île
et c'est pas nouveau que ce soit une île
c'est une île depuis très longtemps face
ils sont des îles en l'occurrence les
philippines donc les philippines c'est
un ensemble d'îles c'est un archipel
depuis très longtemps et il n'est pas
impossible que homo ludens is soit
arrivée depuis le continent asiatique se
soit installée dans les philippines et
ait subi un nanisme insulaires à l'image
de ce qui est arrivé à homo floresiensis
l'homme de florès donc ça déjà c'est ce
que la taille juste la comparaison de la
taille des dents semblent nous indiquer
maintenant la grande question c'est
quelle était cette population ancestrale
domo domo qui a donné naissance à homo
fluzone 6 par nalyse massue l'air et
donc ce que nous indique les analyses de
zanoli et de ses collègues zanoli qui
est un chercheur français d'ailleurs qui
est basé à poitiers si je ne m'abuse
dans bordeaux il est basé à bordeaux
donc clément à nos lits qui nous avait
parlé déjà dans notre autre vidéo de
homo ludens is puisqu'une il est
impliqué dans la découverte et la
description depuis le début eh bien il a
comparé donc il a fait tout un tas
d'analystes sur les dents des analyses
morpho métriques en fait ce qu'il en
ressort c'est que sur toutes les
analyses ou presque aux maux du shônen
si ce n'est pas loin de homo erectus
sauf quelques résultats par ci par là ce
qui veut dire que il est plus
raisonnable d'interpréter aux moldus
zone n 6 comme étant une variante d'homo
erectus qui a rétréci sous l'effet d'un
âne isma suler que de l'interpréter
comme étant un descendant d'homo sapiens
ou de n'importe quel autre espèce du
genre homo à noter que évidemment
puisqu'on n'a pas de dents de denisova
dans cette analyse on n'a pas pu
comparer aux mots lionel 6 à denisova
ceci dit on s'attend quand même à ce que
denisot va soit relativement proche de
néandertal qui a été inclus cette
analyse est homo ludens is ne ressemble
pas du tout à denisot va donc
neandertalensis donc ya pas de raison de
penser qu'il aurait pu ressembler à
denisot bas là on a quand même un signal
assez cohérent pour interpréter homo
ludens is
comme homo floresiensis d'ailleurs comme
étant un descendant d'homo erectus
asiatiques qui c'est qui s'est adapté à
la vie insulaire par nanisme donc c'est
un article qui est très important
puisque ben il trace pour la première
fois on va dire une ligne de parenté
entre lui zone n 6 et homo erectus et
c'est parti pour les rattrapages et
puisqu'on parle et d'êtres humains et
bien on va rester dans les homininés
avec un article de 2021 que j'avais
laissé passer parce qu'il était sorti en
même temps que d'autres trucs super
intéressant et que du coup je les
appelais mais je l' ai vu passer mais
j'ai choisi de ne pas en parler dans les
palais aux news donc je le fais
maintenant pour les rattrapages il
s'agit de possibles empreinte attribué à
un nouvel hominidé de tanzanie donc les
empreintes de tanzanie et elles sont
très connus ce sont les fameuses
empreinte de la et au lit donc vous
voyez une photo ici et donc il faut
savoir que les empreintes de la et oli
qui sont surtout célèbre pour une piste
en réalité non pas qu'une seule piste il
n'existe une autre piste
d'empreintes attribués à des êtres
humains ou du mois attribués à des
animaux bipèdes et sept autres pistes et
bien elle vient d'être étudiée ici dans
un nouvel article publié dans nature's
donc un gros article quand même du gros
papier avec des avec des gros noms de la
paléoanthropologie de temps dedans comme
de silva jérémy de sigma par exemple des
des autorités dans la matière j'ai envie
de dire
et on ses empreintes elles sont un peu
durs à interpréter puisque comme vous
voyez les contours sont pas très
homininés
voyez que comparées aux empreintes de
laetoli ses empreintes elles font pas
très haut minini alors on croit
distinguer un pouce opposable ici avec
le reste des orteils qui serait là le
talon qui est ici une certaine voûte
plantaire plus ou moins ici mais quand
même l'empreinte est super large en fait
c'est ça le truc surtout qui c'est ça
qui
dissuaderait on va dire d'interpréter ça
comme un mini initialement elles ont été
interprétés comme étant une prince et
non une piste d'ours bipèdes puisqu'il y
avait des ours à l'époque
en afrique il y en a plus aujourd'hui
mais il y en avait à l'époque donc elle
avait été interprétée comme une
empreinte de possibles ours d une piste
pardon de possibles ours en posture
bipèdes et là ils les réinterprète
définitivement comme empreinte 2010 et
comme elles sont très différentes des
empreintes d autres empreintes de
l'anatolie celle là est bien du coup ils
disent que ça appartient peut-être à une
autre en point à une autre espèce 2010
n'est qu'ils vivaient dans la région les
empreintes de la et au lit étant
classiquement interprété comme
appartenant à afarensis australopithecus
afarensis
c'est à dire lui si l'espèce auquel
appartient dre lucie
bon le truc avec les empreintes c'est
que en fonction de la densité du sol
vous allez avoir une même espèce va
faire des empreintes extrêmement
différente notamment les orteils ont
tendance à s'écarter quand le sol est
très mou ou à se rapprocher quand le sol
est très dur et puis les empreintes vont
êtres vont être beaucoup plus large en
fait dans un sol mou parce que vous avez
évidemment
le pied va rentrer la boue va
s'effondrer au dessus du pied mais quand
le pire ressort il repousse les bords et
du coup ça fait une empreinte un peu
explosé donc c'est un peu un peu ce
qu'on observe la cua donc c'est assez
difficile de dire à qui appartient une
empreinte et quand vous avez deux
morphologie d'empreintes différentes
la première chose qu'on vous apprend
globalement c'est a surtout pas conclure
que les deux empreintes appartiennent à
deux espèces différentes chez les
dinosaures typiquement vous avez les
fameuses emprunte à 3 doigts et vous
allez avoir plus ou moins de métatarse
imprimé dans la bourre et vous avez
avoir les doigts plus ou moins écarté en
fonction de la solidité de la boue la
consistance de la boue donc il faut se
il faut généralement enfin c'est le
premier truc qu'on apprend en ethnologie
en paléontologie il faut se retenir de
dire à différentes empreintes
appartiennent différentes espèces et
donc la dire que parce que ces
empreintes sont différentes alors c'est
un hominidé différentes il est différent
qui les a fait
c'est à mon avis une
hypothèse assez lourde un produit je
sais pas si elle tiendra sur la longueur
ou pomme mais bon après à côté de ça je
veux dire le chevauchement des espèces
d'hominidés le fait qu'ils aient
plusieurs espèces d'hominidés qui ont
vécu au même moment au même endroit ça
c'est pas nouveau non plus donc c'est
pas impossible évidemment mais faut
normalement c'est quelque chose qu'on se
retient de faire et on termine non pas
avec des homininés mais avec des
mammifères et avec les trucs que j'aime
le plus à savoir de la paléogénétique
parce que je trouve ça fascinant qu'on
arrive encore à extraire de l'adn et des
protéines de
fossiles qui ont qui ont plusieurs
dizaines de milliers d'années est donc
cet article eh bien ils s'intéressent
haqqanis dix russes donc le fameux loup
géant d'amérique du nord qui vivait à
l'époque de rancho la brea grant shaw
l'abri à 7 c'est ce dépôt de bitume très
célèbre près de los angeles où on a
retrouvé des centaines et des centaines
de carnivores c'était un piège à
carnivores donc on a beaucoup de tigre à
dents de sabre et beaucoup de khalis des
russes ne sait pas trop comment traduire
ça mais en tout cas des loups géants qui
ont été retrouvés et qui date entre
c'est ce qu'ils disent là entre 13000 et
50 mille ans et on en n'a pas retrouvé
carancho l'abri ya évidemment mais c'est
le site iconique d'amérique du nord et
donc de deux saisons ils ont réussi à
extraire non seulement des protéines de
l'ancien protéines du collagène mais
aussi un petit peu adn et notamment de
l'adn mitochondrial ce qui leur a permis
de faire des analyses j'ai
phylogénétique basés sur l'adn est en
fait ce qu'ils ont découvert et bien
c'est cet arbre phylogénétique ici avec
le chien enfin le chien et le loup si
canis lupus ici les autres les autres
canidés voilà le loup d'ethiopie le loup
africain le coyote donc les autres
membres du genre qu'à nice qui sont ici
qui se branchent proche du chien et de
loups est ici vous avez donc les lichens
vous avez les pions et vous avez ici les
chacals on nie pas les chocolats vous
avez les chacals qui forment un canada
entre eux et qu'ils appartiennent donc
alors ici les ont noté qu'à nice mais oh
mais là c'est qu'à nice a du stock mais
en réalité le chacal c'est un genre
différent donc en réalité ça devrait pas
être qu'à nice a juste eu c'est qu'à
nice mais sommes hélas mais lupul et la
maison mais la cellule et la adult us et
donc où vient se mettre le le canis des
russes dans cette histoire est bien il
ne vient pas se mettre aux côtés du loup
canis lupus comme son nom pourrait
l'indiquer d'ailleurs golf ça
suggérerait quand même qu'il vient se
mettre du côté de canis lupus et bien
non il va se mettre complètement à
l'extérieur et ça ça veut dire une chose
ça veut dire que la morphologie en fait
du crâne et complètement convergentes en
réalité avec celle du loup la cette
morphologie crânienne que pourtant vous
mettez un crâne de canisses dix russes
et un crâne de khalis ou de bus lane à
côté de l'autre le canis virus on a
vraiment l'impression que c'est juste la
version agrandie d'un crâne de canis
lupus coin d'un crâne de loups ça
ressemble trait pour trait un crâne de
loups mais en plus gros et avec des
muscles en fin d insertion musculaire
plus grande est maintenant en fait c'est
juste une convergence évolutive donc
c'est les deux espèces qui ont évolué
dans une même direction à savoir l'hyper
car niveau rit donc ça déjà c'est une
nouvelle chose et du coup vu que le
genre canis finalement se réduit un cas
ni siemens isc à nice le passé à cannes
nice la transe et canis lupus je
rappelle que les chacals appartiennent à
un autre genre le poulet là bas il n'y a
plus aucune raison de considérer que les
organismes russes sont autre chose qu'à
nouveau genre et donc ils proposent un
nouveau nom de genre et ce nouveau nom
de genre c'est à et notion donc
maintenant qu'à nice virus ne s'appelle
plus qu'à nice des russes mais à une
notion dit russe et s'est confirmée par
cette nouvelle analyse phylogénétique
c'est la grande classe voilà c'était
paléo news je vous remercie d'avoir
suivi n'oubliez pas de vous abonner pour
ne rien manquer l'ancien et je vous dis
à très bientôt
[Musique]